hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by skillshare
and we'll be reviewing
sarah's day new wellness app sunny
now before we get too far into things i
want to chat about
what i've been learning through my
skillshare membership while social
distancing
at home now if you haven't heard of
skillshare they're an
online learning community with a wide
range of
amazing creative classes for exploring
new skills
developing interests and getting lost in
your own creativity
i know a lot of people might be thinking
about some
ways to learn some new skills or
diversify their careers
especially in these really uncertain
coveted times
so as a creator i've been taking
productivity
for creatives by youtuber thomas frank
this has been so valuable for helping me
to
optimize my physical and digital
workspace coming up with templates to
streamline my work
and figuring out when to delegate and
when to collaborate
this course alone has actually made me a
much stronger entrepreneur
so whether you're bored need some extra
self-care
or want to join a creative community
while in isolation
skillshare is a great resource during
these times and of course beyond
and for my viewers and fans the first
1000 people to click the link
will get a free trial of skillshare's
premium membership
and then after that it's only around ten
dollars a month
also you can pause the screen or look at
the description to check out my
disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating
i will be talking about calories and
macros
so of course feel free to skip that
portion or this video
if it isn't supportive to your journey
and of course
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and ring that little bell so
that you never miss out on a video
all right friends let's kick it off with
a bit of a background
on sarah's day so sarah is an australian
health and fitness influencer
who i've actually reviewed in the past
so if you want to see that video you can
check it out
right here now in january 2020
sarah launched a brand new app called
sunny
which combines tips for healthy eating
cooking
and naturopathic wellness from a
nutritionist naturopath
and from sarah herself now since the app
came out
i have received a tsunami of dms and
comments
asking me to review it so i download the
app myself to give you my honest
thoughts
now let's start with a general overview
of what the app has to offer
so according to sarah the purpose of the
app is to provide
healthy recipes for a wide range of
dietary needs
like gluten free dairy free vegan low
fodmap etc
so sarah herself has discussed her own
struggles with pcos
food intolerances and hormonal acne and
has testified herself
that changing her diet has been
paramount to her healing journey
so let's start by chatting about the
section called the healthy
plate which was developed in partnership
with a nutritionist
d zibara
[Music]
so dee has an advanced diploma in
nutritionals medicine
but is not a registered dietitian and
actually nutritionist
is not a regulated profession in
australia
but back to the healthy plate this is
essentially sarah's rules for like
portion sizes and building a balanced
meal
now you all know how important balance
is when it comes to
healthy meals and snacks so this part
was particularly
interesting to me now according to sunny
each meal should have one handful of
greens
at least one handful of colorful fruits
and veg
one handful of starchy carbs one palm
size of protein and three
fingers of good fats and one thumb of
superfood sprinkles which include
premium ingredients like maca
cacao powder and acai powder according
to
the smoothie section so although ser is
australian
i compared these suggestions to the ones
outlined in my national food guide
and all in all i would say that the
portions are pretty representative
of the recommendations for healthy
serving sizes
that would help you meet your macro and
micronutrient goals
so that's great however there are a few
things that i
definitely want to flag first of all i
think you all know what i'm going to say
about the
superfood sprinkles thing
probably not necessary if you're already
getting a decent serving of both greens
and colorful fruits and veg in your meal
already not only do i think it's
kind of unnecessary for most people
following the other suggestions in this
plan
but it also renders the diet pretty
inaccessible to a lot of folks out there
more on that of course in a moment now
my other major
issue with the diet recommendations is
that they are made with the assumption
that everyone is both gluten and
dairy-free
so i know that sarah preaches this way
of eating because it has been helpful to
her
however if you don't have known
intolerances
celiac or allergies to dairy and gluten
you do not need to eliminate them from
your diet
next we're going to put our dietitian
hats on and take a closer look at the
nutritional content
of a couple of the recipes offered on
sunny
[Music]
so let's begin with a savory one one
recipe that i saw online getting a lot
of negative buzz
was the avocado carbonara pasta
now unlike traditional carbonara pasta
which is obviously rich in both dairy
and gluten
two no-nos in sarah's books sears
version
uses buckwheat pasta avocado and
nutritional yeast
sounds great to me after doing some
quick nutrition calculations
you can see that one serving of sonny's
avocado carbonara
clocks out at around 669 calories
with 26 grams of protein 77 grams of net
carbs
26 grams of fat 5 grams of saturated fat
and over a thousand milligrams of sodium
now if we compare this to a lightened up
version from stanford healthcare's
website
that contains you know the traditional
cheese and the traditional wheat pasta
we will see sarah's version has more
than twice the calories
four times the fat and twice the
saturated fat
carbs and salt we are getting a little
bit more protein and more healthy
monounsaturated fats from the avocado
which are really important additions so
it's not like one recipe is necessarily
good and the other one is bad
i say that both can be healthy choices
depending on your nutritional goals
and dietary preferences now let's take a
look at one of sunny's
sweet treats so i decided to zero in on
sarah's
white chocolate cheesecake recipe which
is dairy dairy-free
gluten-free and totally vegan versus a
conventional
white chocolate cheesecake recipe i
found online so
sarah's version has over 600 calories 44
grams of carbs
four and a half grams of fiber 23 grams
of sugar
and 46 grams of fat 19 of which
are saturated fat meanwhile a slice of
traditional gluten and dairy-filled
white chocolate cheesecake
contains around the same amount of carbs
sugar
and saturated fat but almost half of the
total fat
and 150 fewer calories yes you're
getting a couple grams more fiber
and the ingredients may be less refined
in sarah's version
but i probably wouldn't rely on
cheesecake to
meet your fiber or your antioxidant
goals
anyways again it really comes down to
your own
dietary needs and preferences i mean
obviously if you're vegan and you're
gluten free
sarah's recipe fits the bill but at the
end of the day
i kind of think that dessert is dessert
i
love creating recipes that cater to
different dietary limitations like
plant-based
or gluten-free but these attributes
don't necessarily
make them healthier than the og
in fact if the healthified version is
less satisfying and enjoyable to you
it may often lead you on what i call a
flavor hunt
looking for what you actually crave and
the result is often
overeating so you know there's a place
for both of these as long as they're
enjoyed
i say if you want cheesecake have a
cheesecake that you
actually want to eat savor it and move
on
now let's dive into the naturopathic
section of the app
which was created in partnership with
the australian naturopath
hayden keys in the app keys shares
specific
naturopathic medical advice related to
very specific health ailments and
conditions so
i did want to kind of like fact check
the evidence on a few
random ones that popped up for me in the
app one of the first ones that i saw was
about how to deal with
always being cold
[Music]
now the app suggests that this is
typically due to poor circulation which
can be true especially when we're
talking about cold hands and
feet what's the app solution well just
add some warming herbs like cinnamon and
ginger to your diet
okay while we do have research to
support cinnamon and ginger in improving
arterial blood flow and circulation this
is
largely being done on animals or in
petri dishes
so we really have no quality evidence
of its usefulness in real life now keys
also suggest getting blood work done to
rule out a thyroid diagnosis from your
doctor
yes yes and yes while some of the
naturopathic medical advice i found on
the app
felt a little random and maybe a little
out of scope for an app like this
speaking to your doctor to rule out a
deficiency or a health condition
should probably have been suggestion
numero
uh excuse my french not like just
putting cinnamon
in your oats or ginger in your tea now
there are also a number of conditions
that sunny doesn't even mention
that could also result in feeling cold
like raynaud's
atherosclerosis and nerve damage and we
can't forget about the
big one that i would expect potentially
from sarah's demographic and that
is under eating one of the most common
symptoms
of disordered eating is feeling cold all
the time
in fact a study comparing a group of
adults fed a
calorie restricted diet with another one
on a typical diet
found that the dieters had significantly
lower
body temperature if someone is on an app
designed by a wellness influencer and
they're chronically cold
the risk for disordered eating should
definitely
be flagged another problematic example
is around sunny's suggestions on
acid reflux
so first sunny instructs readers to cut
out processed foods refined foods
junk food and fast food and argues that
gluten and dairy are
other major triggers to omit this my
friends
is what we call confirmation bias and it
is
deeply ingrained in this app first the
good
we do have research to suggest that for
those who are sensitive
eating an excess of high fat food spicy
food
chocolate and alcohol can exacerbate
acid reflux now although there are
studies suggesting that avoiding gluten
has been proven to be helpful for people
experiencing gerd most of these studies
are
conducted on people with pre-existing
celiac disease diagnosis
who are medically instructed to avoid
gluten
anyways in other words this is
not a recommendation for the masses as
for dairy
studies suggest that for folks without
lactose intolerance
up to three servings of dairy per day
does not appear to trigger
reflux symptoms even when we're looking
at
higher fat options so again assuming
that you
do not have a medical reason to avoid
dairy or gluten
there's little reason that you should be
cutting it out in fact
while this way of eating seems to work
for sarah's needs i might say that it's
slightly irresponsible of sarah
to be putting her personal dietary
restrictions
onto others on mass when these
intolerances
are a very individual thing finally
sunny's final suggestion for acid reflux
is to consume
chamomile ginger licorice and
marshmallow teas
all of which have been associated with
reducing some digestive symptoms
however what they don't tell you is that
you'd probably need to consume
a lot of it to get any kind of relief
for example
in the case of marshmallow tea studies
suggest that you would need like
two spoonfuls of the stuff steeped in
tea
basically every time that you eat is it
dangerous advice to drink tea
no not at all but if you're truly
really suffering you might also need
pharmaceutical support
and again should definitely be speaking
to your doctor about what will work best
for you
finally the last medical issue we'll be
looking at on
sunny is the app's advice around
treating an
abscess
[Music]
seems like a pretty intense medical
condition for a
wellness app to be doling out advice for
but let's see what they say
for those of you who may not know what
an abscess is
maybe put down your snack for a hot
minute because
i'm about to say a pretty gross word
in short because you're gonna want me to
keep this short
it's a concentrated deposit of pus
that forms when there's an infection in
the body
pus oh that is definitely up there with
moist
in the top 10 worst words
in the english language oh my god ew
david
anyway sonny's first suggestion is to up
your intake of dietary zinc
as zinc helps to build up the body's
defenses against infection
now it is true that zinc plays an
important role in supporting the body's
immune system
there's also research to suggest the
success of utilizing certain metals
as a strategy for inhibiting microbial
growth
in abcessed tissue however again
this research has been done on mice
which is just not a sufficient
base for recommendations to the masses
in my books not to mention even if
dietary zinc
did play a clinical role in abscess
reduction
how many pumpkin seeds or oysters would
a girl need to eat
to like cure an infection i mean
sounds like a pretty pricey endeavor to
me
the next recommendation of said abscess
reduction
is to increase your intake of echinacea
as
they suggest that echinacea can help
boost
the immune system first of all nothing
you eat
can boost your immune system nor would
you
necessarily want it to since an
overactive immune system
is just as dangerous as an underactive
one
and while i get that a lot of us have
like accepted acne
as an immune booster and have thought of
that as like a wellness
fact the reality is that the research
looking at the relationship between
echinacea and immunity
is really spotty and also kind of mixed
a lot of information regarding dosage
potency
and long-term effects remain unknown
with some studies
showing no impact of the herb at all
or even negative long-term effects on
immune health
so yeah not sure that that one
holds up lastly sunny advises readers to
use
burdock root tea tree oil and manuka
honey
to treat an abscess now while burdock
has been seen to have some positive
antibacterial effects
on blood in mice there are not really
any quality human studies out there
that substantiate these wellness claims
in terms of tea tree oil
there was one study suggesting that
applying the oil topically could help to
decrease
wound healing time in those with an
abscess and infection
however again the sample size of the
study was very small
so we would definitely need to see more
quality evidence before making this
the go-to treatment finally manuka honey
has
definitely gained a lot of attention in
the wellness community for
its alleged positive role in wound
healing
but again we're talking petri dish
research here folks
not actual living breathing humans
and while results from this kind of in
vitro research
is always super exciting it is just
a jumping off point for more quality
trials
and really should never be the basis of
important medical advice
for something as serious as a bacterial
infection
while some home remedies like these may
have a role in treating
smaller abscesses if that's the plural
you know they often do need specialized
medical attention
to be drained and treated with
antibiotics
i don't know about you but if i had a
pocket of infected
pus somewhere on my body
i would be getting that looked at a sap
not smearing expensive honey all over it
and throwing back
handfuls of seeds next so i just want to
like
close off this section by acknowledging
that yeah i might be a little salty
and sassy here but i don't have
anything against functional medicine or
naturopathics
i have worked with naturopaths
personally and professionally
and i think that they can complement
conventional medicine really
really well and while i give sarah a ton
of credit for putting a disclaimer at
the beginning of this section
that you know it's not intended to be
medical advice and
more so just suggestions for the
purposes of well-being
i am pretty sure that any er doctor
would be horrified to see a patient
present with an
advanced stage abscess an infection who
thought that putting some extra pecans
on their salad
would make it go away so i would rather
see the section
removed or at the very least whittled
down to reflect conditions which we have
more quality research
to support nutrition intervention i want
to finish
off by discussing one of the big
criticisms of the app
it's accessibility or more accurately
it's lack thereof first and foremost
let's talk about the price
[Music]
what's funny to me is that most of you
who asked me to review this app
didn't really care about my thoughts on
the recipes or nutrition
or even the naturopathic advice it was
actually the
deep dent that it left in your bank
account
i'm gonna be real with you guys this app
is
pretty pricey for what you get to break
it down for you
it is 41.99 for three months
64.99 for six months or 104.99
for a year ouch that's a lot
while you do get to download it for free
from the app store
the healthy plate pantry staples cooking
basics
and nourishme features are all locked
until you cough up the dough
as an entrepreneur myself i fully
appreciate the amount of work that
likely went into creating
this app but i think at the very least a
free trial
would have been nice and even after that
i'm not sure that the value is there
when we consider how this content
compares to
everything else that you can access
online for free
at the end of the day though i guess if
you don't like the price
don't buy the app but what bothers me
more
is the kind of ingredients you'll find
under sarah's pantry
staples so this section features
a list of around 40 to 50 different
items that sarah suggests
are necessary purchases and most of them
apparently need to be organic now i've
discussed my thoughts on organics in my
sorel amore video
here but in short while organic foods do
contain
fewer synthetic pesticides and
fertilizers and are free of hormones and
antibiotics
the research suggests that they
generally do not have any huge
nutritional advantages over regular
conventional foods
and the residue levels found on
conventional foods
are well within range for safe
consumption
it's also still unclear if the
pesticides
that are used in organic farming are
significantly safer than
non-synthetic pesticides used in
conventional farming
honestly though whether or not you
choose organics is a totally
personal choice but i'm bringing this up
because
organic food is around 10 to 50 percent
more expensive than conventional food
which again
adds an element of exclusivity to this
app
so if it comes down to eating enough
fruits and vegetables
or eating less but choosing organic
especially if you're already kind of in
debt from downloading this app
i say your priority should be to eat
enough
period quantity in this case is
definitely more important to me than the
organic label
my second issue with the pantry staple
section are the amount of wellness type
products
that have been categorized as staples
insinuating
that these are foods that you absolutely
must eat for good health
for example this list includes
ingredients like agave nectar
apple cider vinegar buckwheat flour
coconut sugar
bone broth concentrate cold pressed hemp
seed oil
raw honey cacao powder and pink
himalayan
sea salt all of these are healthy foods
absolutely
and all great nice to have additions
but even implicitly suggesting that
these are essential for good
health is kind of off-putting to me i
think it's fair to say that most people
either can't afford
all of these specialty ingredients on a
regular basis
or they live in regions without physical
access
to specialty food shops that are
required to purchase them
and like i said earlier if you're eating
a general balanced diet with adequate
fruits and vegetables as this app also
suggests
the need for organic pink himalayan sea
salt
is very quickly rendered obsolete
after doing some quick and dirty math i
calculated that the cost of a one year
subscription
plus purchasing just some of these
specialty pantry items
would put you back about 300 to 400 per
year
and that doesn't even touch your actual
groceries
and meals this is just not realistic
i hate that people would download the
app
shell out their cash on getting past the
paywall
only to be faced with the false
realization that healthy living
is only for the rich the goal should be
to inspire as many people as possible to
make
healthier choices regardless of their
budget while also acknowledging that of
course
socioeconomics present significant
inequalities to people's access to good
health
so while i acknowledge that accessing
individualized care
is a privileged opportunity hence why
so many people turn to youtubers and
influencers
and apps you might be better off
investing that money
in speaking to a registered dietitian or
another certified
healthcare practitioner who can really
help you make
an individualized wellness plan that you
can stick to
and can afford long term so here are my
final thoughts on the sunny app
summarized as some little quick and
dirty pros and cons
because your girl loves a snappy little
list
pros it's a convenient place to find
nutritious
recipes in one spot it offers
reasonable suggestions on portion sizes
and it may be a helpful resource
regarding cooking substitutions
for those with gluten and dairy
restrictions cons
it offers some misleading nutrition
advice
it shares some far-fetched medical
counseling that
feels a little out of scope and it
paints an
elitist view of healthy eating rooted in
privileged wellness culture
all of that being said if the app's
content appeals to you
offers helpful recommendations that work
for you and your lifestyle
and is within budget then by all means
it's probably a really good buy for you
the beautiful thing about the internet
today
is that there is really something for
everyone
but i did just want to make everyone
aware of what they're getting themselves
into
before they hit subscribe and that's all
i hope this video was useful
to help you make an informed decision
about whether or not to purchase
the sunny app thank you again to
skillshare for sponsoring this video
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
what you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye